the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today we embark on a new phase of our
course signified by the beginning of
block 2 wherein block 1 after indicating
what mathematical structure was in our
quest to get as meaningfully as possible
into the question of functions of
several variables we introduce the study
of vectors vectors were important in
their own right so we paid some
attention to that particular topic and
now we're at the next plateau where one
introduces the concept of functions in
other words just like an ordinary
arithmetic after we get through with the
arithmetic of constants which is what
you could basically call elementary
school arithmetic you work with fixed
numbers we then move into algebra and
from algebra we move into calculus
sooner or later we would like to study
the calculus of vector functions and the
like and why not sooner which is what
brings us to today's lesson we are going
to talk about a rather difficult
mouthful I guess I call today's lecture
vector functions of scalar variables and
if that sounds like a tongue twister let
me point out that what has happened now
is the following when we did part 1 of
this course when we talked about
functions and function machines recall
that both the input and the output of
our machine were by definition scalars
in other words real numbers remember we
talked about functions of a single real
variable now we have at our disposal
both vectors and scalars consequently
the input can be either a vector or a
scalar and the output can be either a
vector or a scalar and this gives us an
almost endless number of ways of
combining these whereby almost endless I
mean for and the reason I say almost
endless is this there are only four ways
what are the four ways well the four
ways are what imagine that X is a scalar
in other words the input is a scalar
then the two possibilities are what that
the output is either a scalar or a
vector on the other hand the input could
have been a vector in which case they
would
to additional possibilities namely the
output would be either a scale or a
vector now the reason that I call these
four possibilities endless are nearly
endless is the fact that by the time we
get through discussing all four possible
cases the course will be essentially
over and to give you some hindsight as
to what I mean remember that we had a
rather long course that was part one of
this course and noticed that part one of
this course was concerned only with that
one case in four where both the input
and the output happened to be real
numbers scalars and it took us that long
to develop a subject called what real
functions of a single real variable
input a scalar output a scalar now the
one that we've chosen for our next block
next combination that we've chosen is
where the input will be a scalar and the
output will be a vector and in terms of
physical examples this can be made very
very meaningful for example one very
common physical situation is that when
we study force on an object force is
obviously a vector but that the force on
an object usually varies with time but
time happens to be a scalar in other
words we might for example write that
the vector F is a function of the scalar
T and rather than talk abstractly let me
make up a pseudo physical situation by
pseudo physical I haven't I mean I
haven't the vaguest notion where this
formula would come up in real life and I
think that after you saw my performance
on the explanation of work equals Force
Times distance and why objects don't
rise under the influence of friction and
what have you you believe me when I tell
you I have no feel for these physical
things let me just make but I say that
semi jokingly the main reason is that
it's irrelevant what the physical
application is the important point is
that each of you will find physical
applications in your own way all we
really need is some generic problem that
somehow signifies what all other
problems look like what I'm driving at
here is is imagine that we have a force
F
which varies with time written in
Cartesian coordinates as follows the
forces II to the minus T times I plus J
notice that T is a scalar as T varies
the scalar e to the minus T varies but
the scalar e to the minus T varying
means that the vector e to the minus T I
is changing is varying in other words
notice that e to the minus TI plus J is
a variable vector even though T is a
scalar for example when T happens to be
zero what is the force when T is 0 this
would read what the force is e to the
minus 0 I plus J that's the same as
saying since e to the minus 0 is 1 the
force when the time is 0 is I plus J
which is a vector you see that vector
changes as T changes but T happens to be
a scalar now here's the interesting
point R an interesting point I look at
this expression and I'm tempted to say
something like this I say for large
values of T F of T is approximately J
now how do I arrive at that well what I
said was as I said you know either the
minus T gets very close to 0 as T gets
large as T gets large therefore this
component tends to 0 this component
stays constantly J or the component is 1
the vector is J so that as T gets large
F of T behaves like J and when I'm
leading up to is that intuitively I am
now using the limit concept I'm saying
to myself what the limit of f of T as T
approaches infinity etc is the limit of
this sum the limit of a sum is the sum
of the limits and I now take the limit
term by term and I sense that this limit
is 0 and that this one is 1 now you see
the whole point is this what I would
like to do is to study vector calculus
meaning in this case what the calculus
are vector functions of a scalar
variable of a scalar input now his Y
structure
is so important in our course what I
already know how to do is study limits
in the case where both my input and my
output with scalars what I would like to
be able to do is structurally inherit
that entire system because it's a
beautiful system I understand it well I
have a whole bunch of theorems in that
system if I can only incorporate that
verbatim into vector calculus not only
would I have a unifying thread but I can
save weeks of work not having to read
arrive theorems for vectors which
automatically have to be true
because of their structure now that's
again a difficult mouthful this is
written up voluminously in our notes
it's emphasized in the exercises but I
thought that I would try to show you a
little bit live what this thing really
means because I think that somehow or
other you have to hear these ideas
rather than just read them to get the
true feeling what we do for example is
we revisit limits and we write down the
definition of limit just as it appeared
in the scalar case and let's start with
an intuitive approach first and later on
we'll get to the epsilon-delta approach
we said that the limit of f of X as X
approaches a equals L means that f of X
is near L provided that X is near a and
I've written the word near in quotation
marks here to emphasize that we were
using a geometrical phrase like if she
can't call one would a phrase but a
geometrical term to emphasize an
arithmetic concept namely to say that f
of X was near L where f of X and L were
numbers meant quite simply that what the
numerical value of f of X was very
nearly equal to the numerical value of L
and that's the same as saying what that
the absolute value of the difference f
of X minus L was very small I just
mentioned that okay now what we would
like to do is invent a definition of
limit for a vector valued function of a
scalar variable one way of doing this is
of course to make up a completely brand
new definition that has nothing to do
with the past
but as in every field of human endeavor
one likes to plan the future and further
sautes after one has modeled the
successes of the past so what we do is a
very simple device and yet very very
powerful
we vectorize the definition that has
already served us so well what I mean by
that is I go back to the definition
which I've written here and put in
vectors in appropriate places for
example we're dealing with a vector
function so f has to have an arrow over
it moreover since f of X is a vector
anything that it approaches as a limit
by definition must also be a vector so
that means the L must also be arrow
wised all right put an arrow over the L
on the other hand the X and the a remain
alone left alone because after all they
are just scalars remember again X and ay
are inputs of our function machine and
in the particular investigation that
we're making our input happens to be a
scalar it's only the output that's a
vector so let's go back and just as I
say arrow eyes are vectorized whatever
has to be vectorized here
so I now have a new definition
intuitively the limit of the vector
function f of X as X approaches a is the
vector L means that the vector f of X is
near the vector L provided that the
scalar X is near the scalar a now the
point is that the X is near a doesn't
need any further interpretation because
a and X are still scalars the question
that comes up now is twofold first of
all does it make sense to say that f of
X is near L does that even make sense
when you're talking about vectors the
second thing is if it does make sense is
it the meaning that we want it to have
does it capture our intuitive feeling
let's take the questions in order of
appearance first of all what does it
mean to say that f of X the vector f of
X is near the vector L in fact let's
generalize that given any two vectors a
and B what does it mean to say that the
vector a is near the vector B now what
my claim is is
let's draw the vectors a and B as arrows
in the plane here let's assume that they
start at a common origin which we can
always assume of course to say that a is
nearly equal to B somehow means what
that the vector a should be very nearly
equal to the vector B well remember if
two vectors start at a common point the
only way they can be equal is if their
heads coincide consequently with a and B
starting at a common point to say that a
is nearly equal to B should mean that
the distance between the head of a and
the head of B should be small but how do
we state the distance between the head
of a and the head of B notice that that
has a very convenient numerical form
namely the vector that joins A to B can
be written as either a minus B or B
minus a depending on what sense you put
on this we don't care about the cents
all we care about is the magnitude let's
just call this length the magnitude of a
minus B and now we're in business namely
we say look at to say that a is near B
means that a is nearly equal to B which
in turn means that the magnitude of a
minus B the vector magnet that the
magnitude of the vector what vector the
vector a minus the vector B is small and
keep in mind that I'm now using small as
I did arithmetic alee because even
though a and B are vectors and so also
is a minus B the magnitude of a vector
is a number note this very important
thing once even when I'm dealing with
vectors as soon as I mentioned magnitude
I'm talking about a number in other
words then I now define a to be near B
to mean that the magnitude of the
difference between a and B is small and
again question - does that capture my
intuitive feeling and the answer is yes
it does that I want a to be near B to
mean that they coincide nearly coincide
and that is the same as saying that the
magnitude of a minus B is small at any
rate having gone through this from a
failure intuitive point of view
let's now be revisit limits more
rigorous
and rewrite our limit definition in
terms of epsilon and Delta's and by the
way I hope this doesn't look like
anything new to you what I'm going to be
talking about next it's our old
definition of limit that was the
backbone of the entire part 1 of this
course
I not only hope that it looks familiar
to you I hope that you read this thing
almost subconsciously as second nature
by now
but the statement is what the limit of f
of X as X approaches a equals L means
given any epsilon greater than 0 we can
find a delta greater than 0 such that
whenever the absolute value of x minus a
is less than Delta but greater than 0
the implication is that the absolute
value of f of X minus L is less than
Epsilon now if I go back to my
structural properties again it seems to
me that what my first approximation at
least for a rigorous definition to
limits our vector functions should be to
just as I did before read through this
definition verbatim don't change a thing
but just vectorize what has to be
vectorized and because this definition
that I'm going to give is so important I
elect to rewrite it and what you're
going to see next is nothing more than a
carbon copy so to speak of this only
with appropriate arrows being put in
namely I am going to give as my rigorous
definition of the limit of f of X as X
approaches a equals the vector L it's
going to mean what given epsilon greater
than zero I can find Delta greater than
0 such that whenever the absolute value
of X minus a is less than Delta but
greater than zero the implication is
that the magnitude see I don't say
absolute value now because notice I'm
not dealing with numbers these are
vectors but the magnitude of f of X
minus L must be less than Epsilon now
you see what I've done I've obtained the
second definition from the first simply
by appropriate vectorization what I have
to make sure of is what that this thing
still makes sense and notice that it
does notice that what this says in plain
English is what that if X is
efficiently close to a what the
difference in the magnitude of the
difference between these two vectors is
as small as we wish but we call that
magnitude what the distance between the
two vectors it says what correlating our
formal language with our informal
language this simply says what that we
can make f of X as near to L as we wish
just by picking X sufficiently close to
a so now what that tells us is that the
new limit definition makes sense just by
mimicking the old definition and what do
we mean by mimicking we mean vectorize
the old definition go through it word
for word and put in vectors in
appropriate places now let's see what
this means structurally that's the whole
key to our particular lecture today the
structural value of this for example
what was some of the building blocks
that we based calculus of a single
variable on remember derivative was
based was defined as a limit and
therefore all of our properties about
derivatives followed from limit
properties well among the limit
properties that we had for part one
where what input and output were scalars
the limit of a sum was equal to the sum
of the limits and the limit of a product
is equal to the product of the limits
and remember in all of our proofs we use
these particular structural properties
you see the next thing we would like to
know so after all these structural
properties once even though they're
called theorems essentially they become
the rules of the game
once we've proven them in other words
once we've proved using Epsilon's and
deltas that this happens to be true
notice that we never again use the fact
that these are Epsilon's and Delta's
that we have epsilon deltas when we use
this particular result we just write it
down because once we've proven it we can
always use it in other words what I'm
really saying is let me vectorize this
now I'll put a question mark now because
you see I don't know if this is true for
vectors I don't know if the limit of a
sum is the sum of the limits when we're
dealing with vectors rather than with
scalars but notice what I've done
I have structurally plagiarized from my
original definition all I did was I
vectorized it you see what I'm going to
have to do is to check from my original
definition whether these properties
still hold true I'm going to talk about
that in a minute let me just continue on
for a while see similarly over here we
talked about the limit of a product
equaling the product of the limits so
again we'd like to use results like that
somebody says well let's vectorize I
want to show you what I mean by saying
that after you vector eyes you have to
be done careful that you don't just go
around saying look at this is legal I
put arrows over everything sure it's
legal but you may not have anything
that's worth keeping look at this
expression what our F and G in this case
the way I've written it these happen to
be vectors see they're both arrow eyes
right they're vectors have we talked
about the ordinary product of two vector
functions and the answer is no when we
have two vector functions we must either
have a dot or a cross in here the dot
product or the cross product and if
we're not going to put a dot in here the
best we can talk about is scalar
multiplication in other words let me
before you tend to memorize this let me
cross that out because this is ambiguous
it doesn't make sense and what I am
saying is that I'm done unfortunately
but if I want to be rigorous about this
that happens to be three interpretations
here namely I can do what I can think of
f of X as being a scalar and G of X as
being a vector or I can think of f of X
and G of X as both being vector
functions but in one case having a dot
product and the other case the cross
product in other words to vectorize this
particular equation i guess what i have
to do is write down these three
possibilities namely notice in this case
this is what this is a scalar multiple
of a vector function granted that the
scalar multiple is a variable in this
case this
makes sense namely for a fixed X for a
fixed X f of X is a constant and G of X
is a vector a constant times a vector is
a vector for a fixed X F and G here are
fixed vectors and I can talk about the
dot product of two vectors and for a
fixed X over here f of X and G of X are
again fixed vectors and consequently I
can talk about their cross product and
the question is will these properties
still be true when we're dealing with
vector functions the answer happens to
be yes but it's not yes automatically in
other words what we're going to do in
the notes is to mimic to prove these
results for vectors what we are going to
do is to mimic every single proof that
we gave in the scalar case only
replacing scalars by appropriate vectors
whenever this is supposed to happen the
trouble is that certain results which
were true for scalars may not
automatically be true for vectors let me
give you an example somehow or other to
prove that the limit of a sum was equal
to the sum of the limits we use the
property of absolute values that said
that the absolute value of a sum was
less than or equal to the sum of the
absolute values okay and we proved that
for numbers suppose I now vectorize this
see this is this now means magnitudes
right and if a and B are any vectors in
the plane a and B no longer have to be
in the same direction how do we know
that vector addition has the same
magnitude property that scalar addition
has C can we be sure that this recipe is
true well let's go and see what this
recipe means you know this by the way
this does happen to be true in vector
arithmetic and it happens to be known as
the triangle inequality and the reason
for that is if I draw a triangle calling
to the sides a and B respectively and
the third side see we do know from
elementary geometry that the sum of the
lengths of two sides of a triangle is
greater than or equal to the length of
the third side of the triangle what I'm
driving at now is let me just vectorize
this and show you something that I think
is very cute here if I put arrows here
this becomes the vector a now this
becomes the vector B this becomes the
vector C okay but in terms of our
definition of vector addition notice
that C goes from the tail of a to the
head of B a and B aligned up properly
for addition so this is the vector a
plus B now state the triangle inequality
in terms of this picture the triangle
inequality says what the third side of
the triangle well what length is this if
the vector is a plus B the length is the
magnitude of a plus B must be less than
or equal to the sum of the lengths of
the other two sides but those are just
this and that verifies the recipe that
we want in other words it's going to
turn out that every vector property that
we need are willing by need that happen
to be true for scalar calculus is going
to be sufficient in vector calculus as
well for example when we proved the
product rule for scalars the not the
product rule but the limit of a product
was the product of limits
we use such things as the absolute value
of a product was equal to the product of
the absolute values notice for example
in terms of case 1 over here if I better
eyes be
and leave a is a scaler the magnitude of
a times the vector B is equal to the
magnitude of a time's the magnitude of B
just by the definition of what we meant
by a scalar multiple after all a times B
meant what you just kept the direction
of B constant but multiplied B by the
magnitude of a B meaning what by AFA was
positive minus a if a was negative this
is certainly true by the way there is a
very important caution that I'd like to
warn you about and this is done in great
detail on the notes it's very important
to point out that when I vectorize this
in terms of a dot and a cross product it
is not true that the magnitude of a dot
B is equal to the magnitude of a time's
the magnitude of B you see what I'm
really saying here is how was a dot B
define a dot B by definition was what it
was the magnitude of a time's the
magnitude of B times the cosine of the
angle between a and B notice that if I
take magnitudes here want to keep this
separate so you can see what I'm talking
about here look at this factor here can
be no bigger than 1 but in general it's
going to be less than 1 in other words
notice that the magnitude of a dot B is
actually less than or equal to the
magnitude of a time's the magnitude of B
in fact it's equal equality holds only
if this is a 0 degree angle or a 180
degree angle because only then as the
magnitude of the cosine equal to 1
similar result holds for the cross
product the interesting point is and I'm
not going to take the time to do it here
because I want this lecture to be
basically an overview but the important
point is that you don't need equality to
prove our limit theorems remember every
one of our limit theorems was a string
of inequalities and actually and as I
say I'm going to do this in more detail
on the notes the only result that we
needed to prove theorems even in the pot
1 section of our course was the fact
that the less than or equal pot be valid
the fact that it was equal when we were
dealing with numbers was like frosting
on the cake we didn't need
that's stronger condition the key
overview that I want you to get from
this present discussion is that when we
vectorize our definition of limit that
that new definition having the same
structure as the old meaning that all
the properties of magnitudes of vectors
that we need are carried over from
absolute values of numbers all previous
limit theorems what do I mean by all
previous limit theorems I mean all the
limit theorems of part 1 of this course
are still valid and with that in mind I
can now proceed to differential calculus
namely what going to do the same thing
again I write down the definition of
derivative as it was in part 1 of our
course and now what I do is I just
vectorize everything in sight provided
it's supposed to be vectorized remember
X + Delta X of scalars here F is the
function
I just vectorize our definition the
first thing I have to do is to check to
see whether the new expression makes
sense notice that the numerator of my
bracketed expression is now a vector the
denominator is a scalar and a vector
divided by a scalar makes perfectly good
sense in other words this is can be read
as what the scalar multiple 1 over Delta
X times the vector f of X plus Delta X
minus f of X so this definition makes
very good sense it captures the meaning
of average rate of change because you
see it's what it's the total change in F
over the change in X equal to Delta X so
it's an average rate of change again
that's discussed in more detail in the
text and in our notes and in the
exercises but the point is that since
every derivative property that we had in
part one of our course followed from our
limit properties the fact that the limit
properties are the same for vectors as
they are for scalars now means that all
derivative formulas are still valid in
other words the product rule is still
going to hold the derivative of a sum is
still going to be the sum of the
derivatives the derivative of a constant
is still going to be 0 and keep this in
mind it's very important
I could read arrive every
one of these results from scratch as if
scalar calculus had never been invented
just by using my basic epsilon Delta
definition the beauty of structure is is
that since the structures are alike you
see since they are played by the same
rules of the game the theorems of vector
calculus are going to be precisely those
of scalar calculus and I don't have to
take the time to read arrive them all as
I say in the notes I read arrive a few
just so you can get an idea of how this
translation takes place at any rate let
me close today's lesson with an example
let's take motion in a plane let's
suppose we have a particle moving along
a curve C and the motion of the particle
is given in parametric form meaning we
know both the X and the y coordinates of
the particle at any time T as functions
of T notice by the way that what
requires two equations in scalar form
can be written as a single vector
equation namely at time T let's say at
time T the particle is over here notice
that if we now let R be the vector from
the origin to the position of a particle
that R is a vector right because to
specify our I not only have to give its
length I have to give its direction R is
a vector which varies with our scalar T
all right so R is a vector function of
the scale of T now what is the I
component of our well the I component is
X so and the J component is y
notice that the pair of simultaneous
parametric scalar equations X equal X of
T y equals y of T can be written as the
single vector equation R of T equals x
of T I plus y of T J where X of T and Y
of T are scalar functions of the scalar
variable T okay now the question comes
up wouldn't it be nice to just take the
R DT here I mean that's opposed
motivated as you can get let
meaning what let's see what happens I
know how to differentiate now I'm going
to use the fact that the derivative of a
product of a sum is the sum of the
derivatives that I and J are constants
and the constant times a function to
differentiate that you skip over the
constant and differentiate the function
X of T and Y of T are scalar functions
and I already know how to differentiate
scalar functions so all I'm going to
assume now is that X of T and Y of T are
differentiable scalar functions which
means now that instead of just talking
about motion in the plane I'm assuming
that the motion is smooth at any rate I
now differentiate term by term and look
what I get this is what its DX DT times
i plus dy/dt times j in other words the
i dt is this particular vector and this
particular vector is fascinating why is
it fascinating well for one thing let's
compute its magnitude the magnitude of
any vector in I and J components is what
the square root of the sum of the
squares of the components in this case
that's the square root of the X DT plus
the squared plus dy DT squared but
remember from part 1 of our course this
is exactly the magnitude of the s DT
where s is AK length remember I put the
absolute value sign in here because we
always take the positive square root
those who we're assuming that arc length
is traversed in a given direction at a
particular time T but what is d s DT
it's the change in arc length with
respect to time and that's precisely
what we mean by speed along the curve on
the other hand if we look at the slope
of the Arditi it's what it's the slope
is determined by what you take the J
component which is dy DT divided by the
I component which is the X DT by the
chain rule we know that that's dy DX
therefore the vector dr/dt
has its magnitude equal to the speed
along the curve and it's Direction is
tangential to the curve and what better
motivation than that to define a
velocity vector after all we've already
done that in elementary physics in
elementary physics what was the velocity
vector defined to be at a given point it
was the vector
whose direction to the curve whose
Direction was tangential to the path at
that point and whose magnitude was
numerically equal to the speed along the
curve that the particle had at that
point and that's precisely what dr/dt
has in other words what we have done is
given a self-contained mathematical
derivation as to why the derivative of
the position vector R with respect to
time should physically be called the
velocity vector and then again
analogously to ordinary physics if V is
the velocity vector we define the
acceleration vector to be the derivative
of the velocity vector with respect to
time now I was originally going to close
over here but my feeling is that this
seems a little bit abstract to you so
maybe we should take a couple of more
minutes and do a specific problem let's
take the particle that moves along the
path whose parametric equations are y
equals T Q plus 1 and x equals T squared
in other words notice that for a given
value of T T is a scalar for a given
value of T I can figure out where the
particle is at any time along the curve
for example when the time is 2 when T is
2 X is 4 y is 9 so at t equals 2 the
particle is at the point 4 comma 9 etc
notice that to understand this problem
one does not need vectors but if one
knows vectors one introduces the radius
vector R what is the radius vector it's
I component is the value of x and it's J
component is the value of y so the
radius vector R is T squared i plus t q
plus 1 j now by these results I can very
quickly compute both the velocity and
the acceleration of my particle at any
time namely to find the velocity I just
differentiate this with respect to T
this is going to give me what the
derivative of T squared is 2 T the
derivative of T cubed plus 1 is 3 T
squared so my velocity vector is just 2
TI + 3 T squared J now to get the
acceleration vector I simply have to
differentiate the velocity vector with
respect to time and I get what 2
I plus six TJ and I now have the
acceleration the velocity and by the way
the position of my particle at any time
T in particular since I've already
computed that the particle is at the
point 4 comma 9 when T is 2
let's carry through the rest of our
investigation when T is 2 when T is 2
notice that in vector form R is equal to
4 I plus 9 J V is equal to 4 I plus 12 J
and a is equal to 2i plus 6 plus 12 J
pictorially and by the way to show you
how to get this all I'm saying here is
that if we come back here recalling that
T cubed is T squared to the three-halves
power this simply says that Y is equal
to x to the three-halves plus 1 so I
drew the path in just so it shouldn't
get an idea of what's going on over here
all I'm saying is when somebody says
where is the particle at time T equals 2
it's at the point 4 comma 9 and notice
the correlation again the point 4 comma
9 is the point at which the vector 4i
plus 9j terminates because you see that
vector originates at 0 0 I can compute
the velocity vector namely what the
velocity vector has its slope equal to 3
12 over 4 and it's magnitude is the
square root of 4 squared plus 12 squared
that's the square root of 160 which is
roughly 12 and 1/2 I can now draw that
velocity vector to scale in a similar
way the slope of the acceleration vector
at that point is 12 over 2 which is 6 so
the mat so the slope is 6 that's a
pretty steep line here and the magnitude
is 1 the square root of 4 plus 144 the
square root of 148 which I just call
approximately 12 to give you a rough
idea I can draw this into scale as well
in other words in just one short
overview lesson notice that we have
introduced what we mean by vector
functions what we mean by limits we've
inherited the entire structure of part
one I can now introduce a position
vector differentiate it with respect to
time to find velocity
acceleration and I'm in business being
able to solve vector problems in the
plane kinematics problems if you will
we're going to continue on in this vein
for the remainder of this block we have
other coordinate systems to talk about
next time I'm going to talk about
tangential and normal components are
vectors and the like but all the time
the theory that we're talking about is
the same namely we are given motion in a
plane and we can now in terms of vector
calculus study that motion very very
effectively at any rate until next time
goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate